I mean me and Destiny we did a uh uh
reaction video earlier to Andrew Tate uh
documentary and I asked Destiny like why
do you think so many guys like listen to
Andy Tate or resonate or you know follow
his his um lead and like you know it's a
lot of guys you know they're looking for
that leadership they're looking for
somebody like a father father figure
like a role model to to kind of you know
stand behind because they feel like
they're they're the guys they're the
demographic that is not being heard do
you get what I'm saying whereas like if
you look at current Society like it is
actually it's actually more Geared for
women to be in positions of like you
know uh changing the the mindset of
people do you get what I'm saying no it
is it's actually